oh he's got to calculate this Prague but
you don't envy him he's just got to push
and Hope
nothing else to do now White's Pawn is
about to land on A7
I think you're right Peter is just too
slow and D5 throwing a spanner in the
works but
that one can just be captured
and then Queenie too that's the idea and
then try to give A7 Queen A6 check
very interesting we'll forget about the
compute accessing that move this is
fighting is fighting for his life
we need to on the board really clever
practical try here easy to get nervous
as Arjun will he offer a queen trade
he needs to make sure he's not getting
checked too much if he pushes his Pawn
forward maybe he can still get away with
it but uh scary stuff
for both sides
okay he does offer degrees
and then we push HD before you go
exactly Queen takes the photo K8 and
hdh2 before white reaches the with Pawn
to B5
wow so Prague has the sense that for the
first time in this game really he can
trade Queens in there he we go
concretely it does work
White's apron ran too far away from its
uh it's supporter there on the B file
and
we're going to get a broken game where
whites are pulling up but
you know easy to decide this computer
says drawers Peter yes it is a draw I
mean Prague is out of trouble and look
at this he feels unbeck that's that's
the body language we are seeing and
Arjun in a State of Shock it looked like
okay then of course I can trade Queens
because my pawns are cleaning but no
chess is crazy chess is crazy and the
skill level of these players is crazy
Prague so resourceful so tenacious it
looked dead lost it looked like he was
dead and buried uh that apron about to
win the game but suddenly that pawn is
falling and arjun's got a gamble here
and E5 is only movable computer for
white to save the game so critical is
this possession that is not obvious
Peter because it looks like it does
nothing E5 black will just play G5
yes
I don't think that's easy
yeah not not at all it's impossible I
would say it's impossible
or he's reaching towards it Arjun
what is even the idea it's not just E5
alone it's the idea connected with it
that's going to be difficult to find
with under 10 seconds now Eric I see
he doesn't find it B6 but surely this
just allows Black's Rook to get behind
he has G5 wins look C7 check
he goes back to the eight rank this this
is the point yeah it looks like this
should be terrible for black but if
Prague goes back with the King
it's winning for him
how is he winning where does he hide
with his King
well if you keep on checking me then hit
zigzags his King all the way to d8
hmm
and Black's pawns are just too far
Advanced Black's G and H pawns will beat
the white Rook later on
and look at Prague I mean he senses that
wow I can maybe win this game
he's on the brink massive turnaround and
Rook B6 comes with a check that is the
key Tempo white doesn't have time to win
that black Rook for the B Pawn and the
black pawns are just going to push
well but now G4 only move H2 Rook H7 is
a draw which basically if if you are
calm enough you understand with few
seconds you never know
you never know but G4 is logical pawns
on the sixth rank or here the third rank
will beat a lone Rook yeah but by G4
Rook H7 Rook takes B7 sacrificing the
look and then the two connected pawns
are winning the race it's uh study like
stuff and Prague goes for it study like
stuff but we all know Prague does his
end game studies he's so good at
calculation I think we'll see that
variation on the board Peter
I Regice he's moving towards his Rook he
just lost control and it's all Fallen
apart
from H7 you can see the nerves there The
Rook landed in the middle of two squares
almost uh not placed well on the H7
Square now Rook takes B7 is that the
only winning move
it's the only evening movie as otherwise
it's a draw very difficult and plug is
going for it
he's going for it and he's gonna make a
new Queen these pawns are too strong
we might see an endgame rook and pawn
against the queen and it might be
winning but that will take a long time
okay still some technique needed by
Prague he's about to make a new Queen I
guess he has to snap off that pawn now
and hope and pray
but also the problem is that his look is
not connected to his King yeah so it's
very tricky to find the way to
coordinate forces
in the first place
yeah if you could Land The Rook on F5 or
a similar Square protected by the pawn
then maybe some holding chances
yeah in the future chat never think of
pushing that jeep on I mean these
players are genius for a reason G4 was
amazing
and look at prague's body language he
knows he's got this in the bag
any at all no not really I mean with 10
seconds increment
Prague
is met by King C3 no more checks blue
cannot connect
and it's game over
yeah Beautiful by Prague using this
technique of the queen
A4 it was Tanya's favorite motive Queen
A4 was winning on the spot and Prague
has
played it instantly yeah you can tell
these guys they've studied their queen
versus Rick and games and there we see a
handshake white was about to get
checkmated or lose his rook and Peter
what a turnaround we just saw we thought
Eric is he was going to take the win he
had a beautiful position extra pawn and
the queen trade led to that turnaround